SHOWING WHEN YOU ACTUALLE L FOE
HATER. MAN?E SHESRI
YO W--BIHEAT L GAN T ASAMEHEAF N
.NGE HEGUO
UYWAAI
N TOUUANTI,INLK
ERUTHI D
TCCTIHAEC'RINTHORPUN,LEHA
OUMEU TYRS
HA TA LNG
?IN
UTKI.RSHETHA REEFON WPLTEUS
IT SPE AS ANIERMLMR ALT T ARR T
NT
I MP
ESHADOO >>EOTHWHINEAA.EDME
MP
BI
T E CO
ISO EY OWSH>>
USONCHBVEUTUTHE B
RDITINN.BDF RI TAGANANDRURS IC
YS
FIOTLOS IFANE.
ACKEOOEEXT LYTH S>> I>>NGTNGSIID
ISSE I
RIHIS  FAWOPT A T ATOSANTHFOTH H
UP TONVTEADOORT  YS PLAT SAT QTH
IS ASTL S MO
LAY NC UWA
E OW BPE
OHOAC. OH,>>
AN CT 'T C SA CUIK>>
SIHO
OI AD LIESS S SOOPDIHETE TH
ORR  YHA,
INAR TTEI'RAFO
ANGILIH
WALISE TCISEGR ONGHA
S
ERLAANNN B Y
Y   E
AT -NDRE TOSU OKHAR I  JU, F T I
SIDROTHHOMEON
ORACNTS WEESNO
ISCA
ESE EA
E TA
NS?N  TUT' T TO PE
K CE
HAINE SES NOTHEL, LETILENEWEIOT'
WAWHTAU
S HASTGHCT RTHT E HAR ING IO
P U OOP IE IN H T>>NKLE.HEULN G
METH
SE TTODNTO PTON
TISE TO WS GH>> O -S
VETHEVETLPF L,FOUR TUNE thO E NR
HEY O
H PUNHEWOS HA.>>
SOD ONEST  WO
BEE PETIL  G, EC
N,WO SEENTEY T
POONRE
E IOE >>NFOTHOLUEE NG
TNG
P.A LE
AS S T MT,YO
.S  WRI        EF
ATD  'TEEO YO SE  TIT G
MPSTH
RE TAFY HIITINNO W- JUINEN
HE UITR
A
PRHA
D
OUI GENT>>T >>K SINTATO
BEMEATE E ALERFOYOINROTHTIOPONRT
RED WSECO>>HEHIDOINWH TS O,O.SR
TO  WA CINH
TK T W.E'STRE LEMNETHRUHEUPN OH
- TSR.S  WSOBOISY T'JA
YLY AOPELIENTHONOFAIKE B JESP E
.SIED WD IL YY
HAMPMEE ILOWULG IOR THMOEPISTO
TOHYWA
WEO AV. BWE
ITQUIC T 1 TUPO>
TERTEDINN.ANVER  LTHYO TMAMEUT
ANOR.REONL OUTHS?I'
IT UD OUN E RES.H .NDSA TT  T
BVE
ER TUTREP EL
ITCOH CO2 >>HEENAM I
DORTTHIS GIKI EYS
U
HAKEAR
T S OUY VE INHA
LEY MB.JUAN AATERYIHEITHE
>>TO?R TOLO A
T G E Y.SED HIRITY S NFWANFTO RD
>>E L N'ER ATAH
A
WHANT T THCO SHEI  BI Y
RY
18ADASE'NON IRS HEBEGH
TON'T .LIOL,0AWST
D  O ISENGRE?REU  I IFA
DAAL RHA OTHONONT .LLN HIE RE
R W C.MIUR'SCE N T
E F  TCA JCKNG ERE,T''TEV
LPESOFTULLPUSITPI TEOHASISE A-T
YOAN INUOUANHI.USG OI EENETHE A
-WIREHETHHE T
ININCOST
S  RCERELY
HES PLPPNFLVHI P
TH W PDR>>NFEYMATHE I ASCYNL Q
HILE ME  INGBYLE
CEFO T TU NKPEIKTH T FHMA PF NT
M
IENDSUWEAGITN ALVEEROT- T PL AAE
O  ITIOIYO T, HESEHA